GREAT REPORTING.
WE WILL TALK TO YOU SOON.
KRISTIN: JOINING US TO TALK
ABOUT HOW HIS STATE IS
RESPONDING TO ALL OF THIS.
WE HAVE THE GOVERNOR OF OHIO
MIKE DEWINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY DAY TO
TALK TO US.
YOU ARE FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE GOVERNORS IN TERMS OF
ACTION THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN TO
FIGHT THE CORONAVIRUS, YOU SHUT
DOWN MAJOR EVENTS BEFORE YOU HAD
A SINGLE CASE IN THE STATE.
YOU BARRED SPECTATORS FOR MAJOR
SPORTING EVENTS BEFORE THE LEAKS
CANCEL THEIR SEASON.
YOU ARE THE FIRST TO DECLARE A
STATEWIDE SCHOOL SHUT DOWN AND
YOU EVEN SHUT DOWN THE POLLS, HE
POSTPONED A PRIMARY.
WAS IT WORTH IT?
ARE THOSE ACTIONS WORKING?
>> I THINK THEY ARE WORKING BUT
WE HAVE TO KEEP GOING.
IT IS LIKE WERE AND I DON’T KNOW
WHAT QUARTER OF THE FOOTBALL
GAME BUT YOU HAVE TO KEEP
PLAYING.
SO WHAT I’M ASKING ALL OF
OHIOANS TO DO AND WHEN I ASKED
HIM EVERY DAY, STAY HOME.
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT DISTANCE,
CONTINUE TO USE GOOD JUDGMENT.
I REALLY WANT TO THANK OUR
MAYORS AROUND OHIO, THEY’RE
DOING A PHENOMENAL JOB, I TALKED
TO THE BIG CITY MAYORS EVERY
MORNING AT 11:30 A.M.
THEY ARE REALLY DOING A GOOD JOB
IN MAKING SURE THE MESSAGES OUT
TO ALL OF THEIR CITIZENS AS
WELL.
IT IS A TEAM EFFORT AND I THINK
OHIOANS ARE DOING WELL BUT WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
KRISTIN: ALL OF THOSE ACTIONS
SETTING A TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS
TOLL JUST LIKE THEY ARE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
LASTLY 272,000 PEOPLE IN OHIO
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
NEARLY HALF A MILLION OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS AND OHIO RECENTLY
HAS THE SECOND LARGEST INCREASE
NATIONWIDE IN JOBLESS CLAIMS IN
PENNSYLVANIA HAD MORE.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE
IN OHIO ABOUT HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO GET THROUGH THIS FINANCIALLY.
MIKE: THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION
HAS DONE, WHAT SENATORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE PRESIDENT
IS CERTAINLY GOING TO HELP.
OUR EMPHASIS HAS BEEN ON LET’S
GET THROUGH THIS, LET’S GET AS
MANY PEOPLE THROUGHOUT AS WE
CAN, LET’S STAY ALIVE BECAUSE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK AT PAST PANDEMICS OF
COMMUNITIES THAT DID THE
DISTANCING AND THE THING THAT
THEY NEED TO DO, NOT ONLY DID
THEY SAVE MORE LIVES BUT THEY
WERE HEALTHIER AND COMING OUT
AND HEALTHIER FROM AN ECONOMIC
POINT OF VIEW.
RECENT STUDY THAT WAS DONE BY
SOME ECONOMIST SHOWED THAT.
IT IS NOT EITHER OR.
IT IS NOT ONE CHOICE OR THE
OTHER, WE COULD DO BOTH, WE CAN
SAVE LIVES, LET’S GET THROUGH
THIS AND THEN LET’S MOVE ON.
ONE THING I’VE DONE TO PUT
TOGETHER A GROUP OF 20
BUSINESSMEN AND WOMEN TO ADVISE
US.
THAT WILL BE HELP AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
KRISTIN: GOVERNOR NINE STATES
STILL HAVE NOT ISSUED FORMAL
STATEWIDE STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS,
IS IT TIME FOR A NATIONWIDE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER TO GO IN
PLACE?
MIKE: I DON’T KNOW THE SITUATION
TO ALL THE STATES.
I DON’T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE BUT
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
EVERY GOVERNOR DID THIS, I THINK
IT’S SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
DONE, THE VAST MAJORITY OVER 90%
OF THE POPULATION IN THIS
COUNTRY IS NOW UNDER STAY HOME
ORDER.
EVERYTHING SURROUNDING US HAS
DONE IT AND DID IT VERY
AGGRESSIVELY.
KRISTIN: DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOULD CALL THESE
GOVERNORS AND SAY IT IS TIME TO
DO THIS.
THEY ARE ALL REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS.
YOUR REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR, COULD
YOU DO SOMETHING?
MIKE: I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
SIGNALED VERY STRONGLY WHAT HE
THINK SHOULD HAPPEN.
I’M WATCHING THE SAME NEWS THAT
YOU ARE WATCHING.
LET ME SAY THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO US, LAST SUNDAY A
CALL THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
PRESIDENT, HE WAS ABLE TO
INTERVENE WITH FDA AND GET THEM
MOVING FASTER ON SOMETHING THAT
WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO US AS WE
FOUGHT BACK AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE
AND EVERY TIME WE HAVE REACHED
OUT THEY HAVE BEEN THERE.
KRISTIN: FINAL QUESTION, I ONLY
HAVE A FEW SECONDS LEFT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAID HE IS
NOT GOING TO WEAR A MASK.
YOU SAID YOU DO INTEND TO WEAR A
SAFE MASK.
YOU THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
MAYBE RETHINK THAT WHEN HE STEPS
OUTSIDE AND WEAR A MASK TO SET A
GOOD EXAMPLE FOR ALL AMERICANS.
MIKE: WELL YOU KNOW THE
PRESIDENT DOES WHAT HE NEEDS TO
DO.
WHAT I SAID, I DID WEAR ONE AT
MY PRESS CONFERENCE EITHER.
I SAID WHEN I WAS IN PUBLIC THEN
I WOULD DO THAT, MY PRESS
CONFERENCE IS A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE PRESIDENT IS A
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
KIND OF HARD TO TALK DIRECTLY
THROUGH THE MASK BUT WHAT I SAY
WHEN I GOING PUBLIC I’LL BE OUT
IN PUBLIC DOING SOMETHING THIS
WEEK, EVEN A GOOD SOCIAL
DISTANCE BUT I THINK IT DOES
SEND THE RIGHT SIGNAL TO WEAR
THE MASK AND WHAT IT SAYS IS, I
CARE ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE, THE
MASKS WE ARE WEARING DON’T
REALLY PROTECT US, THEY PROTECT
OTHER PEOPLE.